all right welcome everyone for the next
class and we're going to continue on the
the group of defense today so big room
filled a so now I'll show you another
game I played in this opening a
different system okay so it's good to
know a couple of different setups
against the growth in Rafael defense
okay so this game is from 2010 again and
against Grandmaster Becerra stronger
master so he normally actually doesn't
play the groom feel he normally plays
the semi Slav and we've had a lot of
games semi slob or Slav but he played g6
which he was a lot of surprised because
I don't remember Julio playing the
groove of Defense
so I played 93 as expected and again we
don't know the opening yet so you have
to wait for the third move then we gonna
know the name of the opening and now
again we see the groom thought it seems
like a lot of people play group held
against me it's probably their most
played opening against me of any of the
openings because I think it seems like
people see that I have a lot of games
and okay some some good results and
maybe some not so good results so it's I
will do the statistics one day to know
exactly but it seems like I get a lot of
groom felts this days almost in every
tournament and now Bishop g5 ok this is
a more rare move and became popular
probably around 2005 this is when you
see a lot of the top player started to
play this opening so the main line is we
looked at it the main line was to take
on d5 C takes d5 setup C takes D fire
but here we see a lot of major theory
Knight xt v e4 which we saw in a
previous game but here we have Bishop g5
in fact in my recent tournament played
last week actually here the Fall Classic
Tournament I played this move against
Ray Dobson one of the top players in the
US in term and he played the move Bishop
g7 here but in this game my opponent
played Knight e4 activating the night
and now putting pressure on my bishop so
you have to make a decision here what to
do with this bishop and I played the
most popular mobile page four if you
take the knight on e4 then black takes
back with D pawn and this pawn is
actually quite annoying because it's
preventing your Knight from developing
to the normal square so you have to play
some moves like III and Queen d2 but
it's it's not so clear basically so
that's why I play the move Bishop h4 he
takes I take back any place Bishop g7
another move is very interesting is
taking on c4 TTX c4 very interesting
move what a play Bishop g7 III
Katzie five attacking the center and now
when you have doubled pawns it's very
important in chess to do what
uh none double the double points when
you have a chance okay so here we have
an opportunity to do that so I'll take
with my double pawn so take on d5 Queen
takes d5 the advantage why I'm playing
this position for white is white has a
stronger center in this position and
that's usually very very important okay
so here I have a little bit better
Center black has active Queen active
Bishop on g7 but in the law in a long
run if I can complete my development if
I can get my knight on f3 the the bishop
on e 2 I can castle then I have a very
nice position here so it's the matter of
time here if I can get those moves in
I'll be better knight c6
so I played Knight f3 Knight f6 Bishop
e2 just developing my pieces and he
canceled my castle Bishop f5
I also had the same exact position with
the only differences black already had
captured on d4 so pawn takes d4 pawn
takes d4 and I've had this position
against international master proofs
he played Bishop f5 in this position but
now with the pawns not captured I have a
very interesting move here that I can
play with the pawns early you know on
the board still like this this move that
I'm going to play now
it wouldn't be good when the pawns are
exchanged but with the pawns on the ball
it's good so take your time a little bit
Ashish don't rush okay
think little bit so you can understand
what I'm trying to do here let's see if
we can find the correct idea here
I think Bishop f5 perhaps is slightly
inaccurate here so it's better to have
it captured but let's see now Bishop a5
what did I play in this position against
Grandmaster Becerra
okay our Cisco queen bee tree correct
queen bee tree idea behind the smoothest
to exchange my coin with his queen if
you look at the position right now whose
queen is more active black queen is more
active right it's in the middle of the
board it's very centralized putting a
lot of pressure
our acquaint is still on the original
square and the reason queen bee tree is
very good when he takes my queen
I will bring my isolated pawn sorry my
isolated pawn here closer to my pawn
chain okay so that's why this queen bee
tree move is very good move here good
job Ashish very good move positionally
now he takes take back with a pawn now
let's talk about the pawn islands for a
second here
how many pawn islands now black has
black has to pawn islands right one two
so that's one island and that's his
second island so it's basically when the
pawns are split
that's one island so right now I have
very good actually one compact Big Pine
Island okay all my pawns are connected
so it's important to pay attention to
the pawn islands pawn structures because
if you have too many pawn islands that
means you have a lot of weaknesses okay
so you want to make sure you don't have
too many islands okay he takes on d4 and
now I took back with this why do we
think I captured back with the e pawn
here you have a choice here you can take
back with the C pawn or you can take
with the night why did I take with a
pawn here that's the question here to
understand how D
excellent thinking you guys hear that so
if I take with the c-pawn now right
which I did
now look at this position here this one
is what week isolated pawn when upon is
by itself that's isolated that pawn is
usually weak die upon has no strength
that phone is gonna be a problem that
you have to keep defending okay but if I
take this way like I did in the game
look at I have this nice you know nice
unit here that I can try to advance okay
and who is controlling the center now
white right I have more pawns in the
center a very nice Center I have and now
look at my rook I don't even need to
move that rock for a while because that
rook is already on an open file that
rook is actually developed basically now
without moving it because it's on an
open file rooks and they like open files
okay now if this rook fc8 he realizes he
has to do something here so he goes for
this now what do you think I should
start advancing my pawns I should try to
complete my development what should i
try to do here
yes
I'm not sure about Bishop c4
because what is Bishop c4 going to do I
know what you making two moves and then
take the night the value of the night is
less than a bishop you don't want to
spend two ten paise to try to take the
night well we should be five first I'm
not again I'm not sure what are we
accomplishing if he just attacks you
because at the end of the line I don't
know if you see it at the end of the
line it up on dropping you can play c4
first but Richard well not here I assume
right okay well you can play rook AC one
but I just mentioned something you
probably didn't hear that the rook on a1
is actually developed already because
it's on an open file so so if you can
actually recap c1 probably better off
moving this piece here because that way
you're developing a Brooke on f1 that is
not doing anything
it's undeveloped okay so I would
recommend doing that if you get it up
but here I'm trying to gain some space
advantage on a queen side here I have
some pawns here so I want to get some
space advantage here what move you think
I can play here to get some more space
and create a thread the thread that are
she she's trying to do the thread that
you trying to do you keep trying to
remove this night right there eco Bravo
yes before now the threat is to play b5
attack the knight if the knight moves
pick up the point okay so the threat is
to play b5 so he plays a6 of course he's
not gonna let you just do that now
what should I do next but a six weaken
the position a little bit correct
look at that look at dark square
weaknesses now so we have to do
something about that
Aashish
look a tree lifting the rook up away
from this diagonal potentially
threatening to double up the rooks with
the idea of beef I'll look at that the
rooks are going to be lined up on a file
and we have that potential to play b5 as
well okay rook a tree is very strong
with rock FA 1 and b5 he plays a5 trying
to do something I mean I have the
control of the center space advantage on
a queen said very difficult to move for
him so he goes for a break he is trying
to break the position now what to do
absolutely d5 attacking that night
Knight behave well what to do
the knight on the heat doesn't look very
good not to many prospects so he tries
to go here to get to d7 now what should
I do
92 first I see the threat is coming
I see the threat is coming here okay I
see the turret is coming so that's why I
don't necessarily want to do that right
now
so I want to bring the knight here in
fact my destination for this Knight is
c4 b6 or d6 this is where the knight is
going this is called maneuvering okay
maneuvering the night for you know to a
better square okay so these are
difficult moves to find in a game
because in the game most of time you're
looking at direct ideas directly what
can I do right away but if you don't
have anything directly you have to try
to maneuver ability to maneuver your
pieces to better squares is very
important in chess you know so you see
if you watch a lot of grandmaster games
right you'll see a lot of maneuvering
going on here
but besides that I also have a nice trap
for him if he plays 97 I have some ideas
like this and where is the bishop boy
look at that bishop now that look at
that trapped piece right there he could
maybe but it's just an idea you know so
he plays Bishop h6 your idea sheesh
right away attacking the knight here now
where is the night going we know where
is the night going here of course when
you choose a plan I always tell you this
what do you do stay with the plan unless
something extraordinary happens you stay
with that plan okay and now look at
those tempest so he goes to Knight d7 of
course 96 he guarded one but he cannot
guard both first Knight b6 would have
been deadly yeah attacking the rooks so
he has to play 97 I attack and now time
to do what is the last copy of going
awaken is it going anywhere
you are but we're an endgame stage you
know sir ah d don't create holes in a
position don't create holes b5 is
creating squares you want to give up to
c5 square for tonight now our pawn chain
is nice but it's like one guy is
advanced one guy is back one guy I see
that's not very nice looking pawn chain
right so of course punched upon chains I
strong when they go together you know if
one guy is advance one guy is behind one
guys in the middle it's not it's not
very strong when they are going forward
together as a unit they're very strong
so that's exactly what I'm doing
Bishop f8 he wants to get rid of that
Knight see and now it's time to
which move now we take the bishop now we
take that bishop
okay let's evaluate this endgame now as
you can see now white meat a lot of
progress here and what is the evaluation
to you here it's there's no question
about white being better how much better
here slightly better big advantage
winning advantage so you think it's
already that bad for black that is
winning we can say it's winning well the
very next move is very important I agree
it's a probably big advantage / winning
okay big advantage / winning but the
next move is very important okay well
the next move I think it's what should
we do here
well I don't want to lose my pawn here
so this is hanging all right
the bishop is trying to take the before
pawn of course c5 excellent they're
going forward right the pawns are moving
forward now and now I'm getting ready to
play these six as well here this is
looking very difficult now for him so he
plays efore d6
look at that pawn chain they're all
protecting each other now I have a
question for you if he plays 66 can you
find a winning move immediately the move
that ends the game here nice move - yes
aadhi aadhi aadhi so the winning move is
go look at that move sacrificing the
bishop attacking the rook rook goes
backwards thank you for the night if it
takes back thank you for the rook you
still have to use your tactics okay you
still have to use your tactics in end
games remember that okay you use your
tactics in end games so he will Quincy
eight rooks e8 and now rook t1 which
piece is undeveloped
Rokon f1 and do we want to have
undeveloped piece no right we want to
bring the rook here at some point we
have the idea to play when rook d5 and
collect the weak pawns these fans are
very weak here you know I have two
bishops great pawn structure and he's
got a lot of weak pawns as well so
Bishop g7
Bishop g5 I just brought the bishop back
Bishop e5 and now this Bishop is very
strong here I would like to remove this
bishop from here or forcing to get rid
of his strong e4 pawn here which move
can do that which move can do that dink
can absolutely a for yes
F for attacking the bishop and he moved
the bishop back because if he takes on
Poisson then Bishop takes and I am also
attacking b7 and he's he's got a very
weak structure
so he goes Bishop g7 Bishop c4
activating the bishop and putting some
pressure there as well okay
Knight f6
Bishop takes f6 correct he takes back
now a fight on is weak right Rock d5 see
I'm ready to take this pawn then I will
be attacking f7 as well and then I have
this nice vertical idea you know nice
vertical check on g3 as well here so
everything is just falling apart now f5
is hanging f7 hanging and rook is coming
in as well so he played a5 he wants to
do something I mean he's just losing
here so he wants to go for a break you
know but now this lose isn't fun dink
dink there is a tactical trap here if
you take here what kind of trap that he
has in mind here do you see the trap the
tactic he wants to do here not yet
takes look at that and now check and now
this is turning the tables around yeah
and look at that he takes back from very
bad position now he is ok I don't think
I'm winning anymore they're not winning
but it's probably close to equal so that
means you always have to watch out you
can never relax thinking I'm just
winning you know so you always have to
watch out for this tricks so I need to
deflect this piece from here of course
deflecting him away so he goes rook c7
and now
rook takes rook takes now forcing him to
trade rooks but if it takes the rook
here you always have to remember you're
in between Intermezzo right check
he takes check thank you for the piece
and now white is up a piece winning so
he played rook d8 and now I must keep my
d7 part there should be five Bishop c3 a
for just defending III threatening e2
this next move is very important to stop
the pawn king afraid
kingi to
now
now I have a very strong pawn he's got a
pond too but I'm I have an extra pond
and I can get more pants now right so I
have six pounds he has four well what to
do and nothing he can do and now I'm
threatening to play rook e5 rook e8 and
that will just end the game here so he
decides to sacrifice exchange and now
creating another passport b5 with the
threat of c6 creating more passports
so he goes Bishop c1 his only idea only
threat is to get a look on the
second-ranked to complicate the position
that could be easily stopped by okay -
perfect
and he resigned here because next I'm
going to play c6 put the pond behind it
and just continue pushing the pond I'm
also at the exchange here so that's why
he decided that you know there are no
chances for him to continue playing here
he's gonna lose anyway so he resigned so
yeah I think a pretty pretty nice
positional win in the end game okay
where it was just some good maneuvering
happened there
we're gonna continue now and I'm gonna
set up a position if you know this
position don't say it because I think
some people might not know it
some might for now all you need to know
is white to play and win for now
well who knows it except Ashish nobody
knows oh you know it ok ok ok let's can
what ok this position played in a World
Championship Carlsen versus Kuryakin
Carlsen Kuryakin 2 years ago
callsign Kuryakin two years ago in New
York last game of the tiebreak I think
it's the last game right was this Alaska
the tiebreak was a rapid yes World
Championship and Carlson did it how wide
to play and win well this you have to
know the ok if you if you've seen d
that's fine let let's let other our
other players to find this beautiful
combination even Ben knows this Ben
Simon knows this problem wait you were
there when this happened oh so you you
saw it with enliven wrap it wrap it okay
anybody else I mean are these Ben ok ok
let's give a chance to Denny either you
answer so much there let's give a chance
to Dennis go
well what away what a way to win you're
not wind like defend your title yeah
queen h6 brilliant sacrifice well he was
defending his title if you lose this
game then no no this was a critical game
no because they wouldn't play unless
state this clinched it you know this
this win so if he takes with a king
Dennis look at that checkmate so you
lured the king you lure the King and to
see this in tiebreak I mean it's pretty
impressive you know he even looked at
this stuff so now it takes to the pawn
and now the seventh rank is weakened
look at that checkmate yeah people
normally don't look for this ideas I can
tell a lot of people would have not seen
this including a lot of strong
grandmasters this is something you gotta
be very sharp at that moment because
either you see this right away or you're
not even going to look for this so it's
it's this is something you gotta see it
right away otherwise you can spend a lot
of time and you're not gonna see this
because you're not gonna be looking for
something like this but I think before
he went for this he already seen this
because otherwise as you can see there
are some major problems here for white
you know you know if you don't do it
you're gonna get made it here so it's
I'm sorry yeah there are a lot of mates
here so Carlsen found this move and
defended the title against Kuryakin two
years ago in tiebreaks
okay so he's a tie-break specialist the
guy has never lost a tie-break match
every time he tied in bill he tied so
he's a tie-break winner basically
this is a game of another high profile
game played in 2016
played by a former world champion
Vladimir Kramnik against women's world
champion how I found from China and
Kramnik is playing with the white pieces
here and white to play and win yes you
need to try to find a way to win this
this Bishop is very annoying it spinning
and causing trouble again this is again
a calculation some good calculation
needed here but 5 moves
5 moves at end of the line you end up
being 2 pounds ahead and just winning so
ok all right
let's see let's give a few more minutes
to other students here let's see if they
can find it it's not easy I know it's
not easy to play like a world champion
but the good thing is you already know
that there is something when they're
playing this games when we are playing
this games live you don't know where you
know where is the tactic at least one
thing you know here that there is
something here something special Adie go
first move giving up your look
he's gonna get it back I think he's got
the right answer
all right let's see Knight takes d5
Bishop takes the the rushing look at
that funny mr. winner so the first one
we got it uh-huh check check out to the
king he goes here chicka and now and you
take only one and now we count the palms
how many pounds White has five how many
pounds Black has three and that is
enough that is enough to win the game to
pawn advantage okay is the most you can
get but it is sufficient okay sure
there's a nice checkmate if you do death
so you take the rook Bishop h6 and what
kind of checkmate is this checkmate has
a name who knows the name for this
checkmate
what
Boden's mate yes Boden's maid ok there
is a queen sacrifice involved in you
know original Boden's maid position but
yeah this one bishop cuts after squares
are there another bishop checks that's
why two bishops are very strong together
so that leads to the Boden's maid okay
so that's why he has she took oh you
found probably the second strongest
woman player ever in the history of the
game yeah after Judith she was very very
close she got up there 2600 close but
she never quite reached the 2,700 but
she pledged she did ok I'm not I'm not
sure but she played a lot of the that
she got the invites to play with some of
the top players so here check check yeah
ok thanks to everybody for coming see
you next time yep
[Music]